BEFORE MINNESOTA WON IT. BY ALE
KERFOOT.
ERIKSSON-EK, THE REBOUND
THE WILD REALLY GOOD BELOW THE
GOAL LINE.
Y A GUY
DRAFTED BY MINNESOTA AND NOT
ONE GOAL OUT OF THE LEAGUE LEAD
HELD BY LEON DRAISAITL.
HERE COMES FI
HE BACKS BRODIE UP JN.
AUSTON MATTHEWS ACROSS THE LINE.
DROPS IT OFF FOR MARNER.
MITCH MARNER BACK FOR BUNTING
TR
HOCKEY.com.
>> Gord:d:
AND IT IS A LOT TO TAKE ON.
PROBABLY FEELING A LITTLE BETTER
AND FIALA SENDS IT BACK DOWN TO
BOLDY.
LOOSE BEHIND THE TORONTO HOLD I.
AND GAUDREAU STEPS OUT F
>> Gord: KNEW FIALA TOO.
FIALAUSH AND
GAUDREAU, OR RATHER MATTHEWS
GETS THROUGH THE MIDDLE OF THE
ICE AROUND HARTMAN. PICKED UP F.
KIND OF TERRI
BOLDY, W W
THEY GET ANOTHERY FROM MARNER.
WINDS BACK THE OTHER WAY. HIRIN
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS.
>> Gord: BEEN A
AT LEAST THREE TIMES.
PROBABLY FOUR WHERE HE'S BEEN
ABLE TO RETRIEVE THE P PNG WALK
PLAY FROM BEHIND THE NET.
SANDIN IN FRONT.
AND HE MAKES A OR NOT.
>> Gord: A GOOD YEAR IN IOWA
MATTHEWS DROPS IT TO
PERIOD.
MATTHEWS ABILITY TO NOT GIVE YOU
WERE ON THE PLAY.
WITH A CHANCE, HE FIRED THAT
WIDE.
THE WILD WILL WORK THE PUCK
BELOW THE GOAL LINE.
WAYNE SIMMONDS, TOWARDS THE
GOAL.
WAY WIDE.
KAMPF BACK WITH IT. HARTMAN ON .
TO ULL IT FREE.
GOES TO KERFOOT.
HE'LL BANK THAT RINK
ICING.
HE GETS THERE TO KICK THE PUCK